next segment we're finally talking about
the Nintendo switch more specifically
will the Nintendo switch help or hurt
the 3ds this is based on a story that
ran or like an interview that Nintendo
high-ups did which kind of contradicted
stuff they originally said about three
days in the switch I have a story up
first off I want to get your eyes
thoughts we kind of touched on this back
when we talked about the switch around
its announcement but Kelly do you think
the switch will help or hurt or what
effect will have on 3s so I'm the best
example I can come up with that would
support like helping the 3ds is Pokemon
go supposedly bolstered sales of Sun and
Moon so it didn't compete directly with
sun and moon because they were separate
experiences on separate platforms that
were made tailor-made for each of those
platforms and so I think like I'd to
ever viewed Poochie & Yoshi's woolly
world which is a port of the wii u
version and i think that it works better
on a 3ds for example so i think certain
things work betel better on a completely
mobile platform like the 3ds versus the
switch which is a something that Peter
brought up which is it's a console that
can be mobile it's not intended to be
like a traveling handheld and so I think
for the user base that's already like
really in love with her three days like
I carry my 3d s with me everywhere the
selling point for the switch is like oh
you can kind of play it up close if you
feel like it but that's not really how
its intended to play to be played in all
the games that are made for it our
console games first and foremost and so
I don't think they'll necessarily
compete with each other I think the
challenges in marketing and Nintendo has
had that problem before with marketing
where with the wii u they struggled a
lot to properly differentiate that from
the wii for kind of the i don't really
hate using like casual but the more like
lay person or like you know your grandma
who knows what a wii is nintendo called
like the family audience right yeah so
they really struggle to differentiate
the wii u and so i think that's the
biggest challenge is how did they market
it so you know that this isn't actually
a handheld it's something that can be
played on the go but it's not a
replacement for a3d yes there definitely
tackling i think that
problem of audience and perception
really well because all of their
marketing force which has shown adults
yes you've not so many kids right word
literally people you might be right but
the point is 3gs is geared towards kids
right and I think that is a pretty big
differentiator and the switch looks like
a very sort of like high-end device
especially in person like super
impressed with the build quality on that
thing a 3ds to something you can just
toss around like it's made to sort of be
durable it's not really like a refined
piece of equipment so the marketing I
think they might be doing a better job
this time because they are getting
around some of that confusion yeah like
I think you pretty much covered most of
the points you know that really need to
be said I mean there are different
products with different aims so you got
hands-on with a switch in New York about
a month ago right touch at the reveal
North Americans abilities and you were
saying this is not anywhere near the
like you were saying the portability of
the 3ds this isn't something you're
gonna see on the bus a lot right it's I
mean you might see it but it's certainly
not like I don't know about you guys
when I place stuff like on a plane or
whatever I kind of just like keep it to
myself I don't have the world understand
that i'm playing a freaking video game
and I'm you know have a good time the
switch is not huge right i mean it is
the screen is the same size as the
gamepad of the wii u and the bezel
around it is not that much bigger right
so it's not huge but it's also not small
and compact and I think you know again
because the experiences are going to be
made for two more console like games to
play a thing for 15-20 minutes on your
commute forty-five minutes not going to
get as much out of it as if you're
really settling in to play something
else whereas so many 3ds games are like
here's a 15 minute mission that you can
get done and accomplished absolutely
close it up move it move along yeah like
the dungeons in like link between worlds
right there's a lot of dungeons that
game but there there's almost bite size
same like yeah I mean as opposed to
twilight princess the dungeons could
take you like 45 minutes yeah whereas
like what like I didn't like animal
crossing city folk very much because
that was on Wii and it just didn't make
sense to drop into my town for 15
minutes it makes so much more sense on
on handheld I was just like totally
different platforms it yeah yeah yeah it
seems like this in this case my ideal
situation of the switch would be with
seemed like they're going for i'm
playing breath of a wild and then
I don't know like they just showed a
laundromat or something I have to get up
and go semi close by or something or two
like a cafe across the street to get
coffee or to go to the bookstore because
I'm pretty intellectual enough you guys
know this no kidding I didn't think that
you knew how to read but I'm working on
it if I screw up your chat comment it's
definitely can't read um but then the
comments here someone there is an
interview with shinya takahashi the GM
of Nintendo's entertainment planning and
development avision and Yoshiaki koizumi
ed the Nintendo Entertainment Planning
and Development deputy GM they discussed
the possibility of an upgraded model of
switch potential accessories and more
and then we could also talk about that
like how they might update joy cons
outsider just aesthetics like you there
was those there was that concept are
like a month ago or something that
showed what else could be attached I
mean think about any little like in-game
graphic or like little neater or you
know device if it's reasonable size you
can interact with that and put it on a
controller like I think you were talking
about the yokai spinning wheel thing
yeah yeah like it's so simple you just
you just sell that you bundle it with
the game players put that on and are
good to go and that creates a really
interesting proposition because that
means and the switch can transform to be
so many things to so many different
people mm-hmm in terms of power upgrades
it's a no-brainer I mean that this is
not like a weird crazy consult it's like
a tablet tablets get upgraded all the
time nvidia is definitely working on
tech that will surpass what is in switch
the switch stuff is out dated so i would
not be surprised if in 18 months or two
years we saw some sort of announcement
like you know the soybeans completely
off base this comparison but it sounded
more like the way they're describing how
these two executives were saying how
they want to update the switch sounded
more like an android like you can take
take it apart almost and put new joy
cons on or new accessories modular yeah
yeah yeah and then also supposed to like
the ps4 pro the Xbox Scorpio which is
more of like an updated iphone well in
the past though they've talked about
creating tools for developers that allow
them to port between devices ok really
easily so to me that would say porting
to things that are maybe more powerful
or you know coming down the road okay
but yes I think you're correct in your
assumption as well that you can really
tailor this thing with a lot of
interesting attachments yeah but yeah so
and then this interview is with time and
then
on gamespot we were talking about how
also of note were Koizumi's comments on
wheres which stands and relates to 3d s
which is the segment we're talking about
he didn't bring up the 3ds but he did
lay out a scenario which seemingly
leaves little room for it is unless
you're going the route that we're
talking about we're hoping in a tennis
which will be a system that will be the
constant in your gaming life quizzing me
said whereas previously you would play
certain things in your home system in
certain things on your handheld our hope
is a Nintendo switch can be the system
that bridges both those and becomes the
constant system that you're always using
that's interesting this week as they
said that there's not gonna be any
StreetPass which is something that
people love about three years sure
that's that's the reason I carried my
around with me yeah yeah same I always
have it on in my backpack so switch
sounds like it's gonna be if based on
that quote it sounds like you know oh
wait sorry there's more but my hope is
that with Nintendo switch being
assisting that you can play at home and
bring with you you're going to be able
to find more of those moments when we
were able to play the games that we all
enjoy and be able to play them that much
more I mean they're not gonna they're
not gonna back away from the promise you
know in an interview about this thing
being portable right i mean they're
gonna try to sell it from every angle
they can but yeah i'd be surprised at
the 3d estes phased out cuz i hope not a
3d s is one of my favorite things i own
names I can see the DNS line being
upgraded yeah you know I mean soonish
yeah i think it's i think it probably
needs to I mean especially compared to
Vita it's outdated but once you have the
switch next to it you know the
resolution on these screens a sort of
graphics you're looking at it's gonna be
I think underwhelming for a lot of
people we give Nintendo [ __ ] all the
time for their library not being the
best in recent years you look at the 3ds
it's unreal yeah yeah one of my favorite
libraries there is it includes the DS
library cuz those games are compatible
yeah then you have like classics on the
like virtual or sorry I you shop and
whatnot um but yeah it doesn't just
weird that those quotes kind of sounded
contradictory to what they originally
pull laid out ya mean bridging bridging
the gap is probably the interesting part
of that quote for me because like there
were you know all those rumors about
Pokemon stars being like oh the third
version of sun and moon coming to switch
and like there were graphical things
inside me that I thought like oh this
looks extra weird on 3ds like it belongs
on something a little bit like a step up
and so I don't know if that means a
replacement or like extra features that
if you play something on your
medias and then you have you know this
add-on on your switch what like I don't
know what bridging the gap means that's
the that's like the question the big
question mark for me on whether or not
that will help or hurt the three dias
it's what they mean by that they'll
probably leaning more into mobile in
terms of bridging the gap between
hardware yeah honestly because that I
mean that's what they're using for some
matchmaking some lobby stuff ya say we
still don't know a ton about we actually
like kotaku put up a pretty good article
basically saying like yeah we're a month
away from switch and we should really
know a lot more I mean it really stands
it's a question will there be online day
one I don't know have we seen the UI yet
barely yeah barely do you didn't see
anything all right no they had debug you
I at the event that I was at but you
right you didn't see your sorry you were
playing games but you didn't see like a
whole menu or anything right okay
whenever they went to that they were
hiding it and they were doing something
secret I'm serious Oh seriously
seriously they had individual safes next
to each stage well there was a Nintendo
of some other country had put out a
commercial and they forgot to green
screen and gameplay footage over the
tablet and we actually got a look at the
debug me so I did see what it looked
like eventually but then since Nintendo
has shone like a screenshot or to what
it actually looks like in trailers where
they did cover up the green screen
footage you probably just said something
pretty insightful and helpful but all I
was imagining was these thumbprint
activated safes next to each station and
you just sneaking around knocking out in
10 employees and scanning their like
eyeballs not knowing that their
thumbprint scanners and then you
actually didn't what's going on in there
in what in your head I don't know I just
like to imagine you thinking you're
solid snake and knocking you know people
and trust and their eyeballs on come
print thing and then like you do this
they thump really go that's all I need
to do um what it wouldn't be a good
segment to run talk about knocking
people huh go off the rails the last
second we're about to pull in a station
and no um yeah that way you try for
trade everything we ran out of coal one
of those dastardly villains had tied
some 12 tracks and threw it off snidely
whiplash yes hmm who snidely whiplash
hey did you make it up and be if you
didn't what's that from I wish I'd made
it up it's from Rocky and Bullwinkle now
you young boy is that their moose in the
cow
one on the moves right rocky thick moose
Rocky's a squirrel boy I wouldn't mean
that same mistake yeah he's a flying
squirrel to be specific what postings
like sugar gliders that the same thing
as a flying squirrel those things are
shitty you know I'm on one of my house
you want to own one I really want a
raccoon I want to pit reckon I saw when
I my round the other day and he looked
very confused at what cars were and I
did not want to go near because I've
heard they can be vicious but I'm basing
that entirely off the movie elf what I
already vicious I'm just thinking of
what he says is someone need a hug and
then gets yep yeah yep ok let us know
you think are you worried at all about
the switches impact on the 3d s are you
hoping like cali so that it would just
supplement it are you in general looking
for more info by the switch like we are
a month before release almost exactly a
month a little you shorter than five
days and we will know more about the
console in the coming weeks hopefully
we'll get some in the office and we'll
tell you more
[Music]
you